so bill maher real quick i always put
the caveat up top when i talk about bill
maher
i like bill maher bill maher especially
when i was more say on the liberal side
of things or on the left side of things
was probably the biggest influence that
i had as a tv personality as a liberal
in terms of the ideas i cared about in
terms of who i agreed with he has
probably 20 hbo specials i'd say 15 of
them are phenomenal and probably five of
them are in the top 10 of hbo specials
of all time
but bill maher has not gotten to the end
of the road of where liberalism has led
and he's struggling with that i think
and when i've done these videos my hope
is that i can encourage him to see the
end of the road and i know his producers
watch this show
and
supposedly i'm gonna be on bill maher's
podcast which is launching this week i'm
supposed to be on in the next couple
weeks or something i'd be happy to have
this conversation on his show uh which
apparently is gonna be like a two-hour
long forum podcast or we can do it
we can do it there we can do it here
whatever it is anyway
so bill maher went on
ben shapiro's show talking about what
has happened to the left what has
happened to the progressives and the
woke who have sort of destroyed
liberalism and i think most of you are
probably going to agree with everything
he said here but you'll see the
transition from what we just talked
about
um
but when you say woke you know it's
become
and i make fun of it too because it's
become an eye roll
in many ways if woke i assume at a
certain moment and it wasn't that long
ago before we didn't have the term i
only heard it i don't know what it was
three four years ago
five years ago at most when we heard the
term woke and it was like alert to
injustice okay i'm down with that i
always have been i hope
people still understand that about me
but yes it became sort of a byword for a
lot of this goofy stuff
that's what i'm always railing against
that's why like they play me on fox news
now yeah i mean how do you feel about
that because you went from the guy who
was
i i feel
look i'm i haven't changed
at all my politics hasn't changed
they've changed people say to me
sometimes you know have you changed no
it's that five years ago no one was
talking about defunding the police i
never heard that phrase five years ago
that's not me changing that's things
changing i'm reacting to it as i've
always been um you know letting
three-year-olds decide what gender they
are
this wasn't something five years ago
free speech you know used to be a
left-wing thing that we were proud and
owned and now that seems to be under
attack so again i'm i think i've stayed
the same
okay as i said most of you who watch
this show who are let's say
conservatives or libertarians or
disaffected liberals whatever is you
probably just watched
the guy who was the the thought leader
of american liberalism
at least from an entertainment
perspective or from a cultural
perspective you probably just watched
that minute long clip and agreed with
everything he said there these people
have gone bananas the left used to
defend free speech the aclu was a was a
free speech organization thought of as a
sort of lefty liberal and now what i
want to do and i'm talking to you bill
and i'm talking to your producers who
again i know watch this show when bill
says i haven't changed it's them who
have changed and he's talking about
wokeness and he's talking about the
gender stuff and he's talking about free
speech and critical race theory and all
of those things it's like you're right
you haven't changed but the liberals
have there are virtually no liberals
other than you and three or four other
people
um who seem to not understand the way
everything is shifted so if you accept
that everything has shifted but you
still
endorse and vote for people who usher
this stuff in then you're just not
making the final connection right you're
not making the final jump that would
take you to from being someone who
complains about things to someone who
actually
stops the things from happening in the
first place bill maher gave barack obama
a million dollars obama helped usher in
a lot of this woke stuff
now again this isn't this isn't really a
criticism as much as like an
encouragement that i want these people
to finally get it at the end
bill said that you know a lot of this
stuff wasn't happening until three years
ago then he said maybe five years ago i
want to show you a clip and i know many
of you have seen this and i i wrote
about this and don't burn this book this
was one of my wake-up moments i was on
the left i was still on the young turks
network i was a progressive and a bernie
supporter and i was having all of these
thoughts about what the left was what
what was happening on the left meaning
they were calling everybody racist and
bigot and they were silencing people and
shouting speakers down to colleges and
everything else and now i want to show
you this clip from 2015
this is the famous sam harris and bill
maher
versus ben affleck on real time and when
you see the sort of hysteria from ben
affleck it's like there were signs that
this woke crazy angry thing was on its
way and it was actually happening right
in your studio bill you're saying if i
criticize the you're saying that
islamophobia is not a real thing that if
you're critical of something well it's
not a real thing when we do it right
well well no it really is i'm not
denying that certain people are bigoted
against muslims as people that's right
and that's a problem
[Music]
you guys are saying if you want to be
liberals believe in liberal principles
right freedom of speech like um you know
we are endowed by our forefathers of the
national that's right all men are
created no ben we have to be able to
criticize bad ideas and of course we do
no liberal doesn't happen okay but islam
but why is the motherload of bad ideas
jesus so we have we have
like blasphemy
it is it's an ugly apostasy it is such a
basic liberty well let me unpack it
tolerance let me let me unpack but not
for intolerance no of course not
good bill right at the end right
tolerance but not for intolerance uh
that clip which i know probably everyone
watching this has seen and it's been
seen probably 50 million times on
youtube and other platforms that was a
wake up to people all over the world i
when i started talking about that clip
and i did a breakdown of that clip of
every moment of that clip on my channel
from years ago when i had like 20 000
subscribers or something like that i was
getting email from people all over india
egypt argentina saying holy cow the
thing that i've been thinking about the
left
the perfect example of it is ben affleck
they're calling them gross and racist
the clip goes on and on you've all
you've all seen it so so there have been
warning signs that something was
happening that the good liberals were on
the defense right there's there's
bill maher there's sam harris the sort
of good non-woke liberals that were
trying to use logic and reason we're
dealing with people that were not using
logic and reason say ben affleck
that anger that ben affleck had and that
over the top i'm right you're wrong
you're racist that has leaked out
everywhere into society it started
online it made its way into some of
these television shows and now it's
everywhere it's all over college
campuses and the intolerance of the left
and cancel culture all of these things
this is the end result it's what we've
got on our streets right now